foreign
[Music]
my name is Kelly I teach statistics and
data science and on this first slide you
are seeing the beautiful city of
Barcelona Spain and I put that up there
because a week from today I will
hopefully be there
um to meet my boyfriend's parents for
the first time
he is fully Spanish
I very wisely took 10 years of French so
I don't really speak Spanish and I have
been practicing a bit and so that has
gotten me thinking a little about
translating between you know ordinary
languages and translating between
programming languages
and so uh this whole Hook was of course
just an excuse for me to be like hey
everyone I have a boyfriend
um that's him
um
um and so you know I've been listening
to this podcast that teaches Spanish and
uh there's this phrase that they were
teaching that kind of struck me and it
looked like this me gusta Migos sorry
for the pronunciation
um and that ah the bear ah me Amigos was
the point of the episode as kind of a
weird construction for
um what they're trying to say is I like
to see my friends but of course if you
were to translate you know word for word
or literally to English we would be
saying it is uh pleasing to me to see to
my friends which of course is not a
thing that we say in English and so this
got me thinking about that like idea of
a one-to-one direct translation and how
that's not really how languages actually
work
so can we apply this sort of theory of
language learning to programming
languages instead
so I'd like to start off with a pop quiz
it's the first talk of this year's comp
besides the keynote and I'm hitting you
with a quiz sorry not sorry
here's your pop quiz
whoops I don't know why that's not
showing okay you get my pop quiz in
words
this code right here
is the object returned by that code
going to be two-dimensional like a
matrix or a data frame or something with
rows and columns or is it going to be
one dimensional like a vector or an
array
who's going to say one-dimensional
who's going to say two-dimensional
kudos to you people who raised your
hands were two-dimensional after seeing
the one-dimensional now the answer as
you might expect is this a trick
question
um as we know posit is no longer an our
only company
in R this exact code right here taking a
column of a penguin's data set is going
to be one dimensional right that's
yanking out a column
in Python
that thing's two-dimensional that is a
data frame with one column
so this is an example of there is not a
direct translation between these two
rather similar rather close languages
that exact code will run in both
languages and it will produce a
different structure of results
so what motivated this there's a class
that I teach every year at Cal Poly it's
called statistical learning
um and we're kind of upgrading it to
statistical learning with r but then
I've added in the python so this class
is kind of upper level class it's mostly
but not entirely stat majors in their
final years of their undergrad degree
there's no Computing prerequisite I
think we're going to change that
um I'm shutting this off because I'm
getting Echo there we go there's no
Computing prerequisite so any R python
that I use I have to kind of spoon feed
a little bit
um back when this class was first
offered 2020 I didn't teach it it used
kind of a hodgepodge as many of us have
done with modeling right as using you
know carrot and basar and tidy verse for
the data wrangling and just kind of all
over the place
so when I took it over I changed it to
tidy models
um and that was really fun like tiny
models is kind of new and it made it so
much easier to teach it I could go on
but that's not the point of this talk
and then this year for some reason
instead of doing the smart thing and
just reusing my materials with little
tweaks that had gone very well I decided
to translate everything also into
scikit-learn in Python
so I want to tell you what this talk
isn't I'm not encouraging you to do this
this was extra work for me
um without a huge amount of benefit in
the class I'm not trying to encourage
you to teach a bilingual class although
if you're interested I would love to
talk to you about it
I did it kind of because there's sort of
these two funnels into this course and
one side of that funnel is the computer
science data science minors I wanted it
to be accessible
um I want it to fit in our eventual data
science bachelor's program
um and I really wanted to practice and
you know it's one of those things where
like you commit when you're feeling
enthusiastic and then you're forced into
it right so I wanted to practice python
I wanted to pick up quarto which is nice
for using both
um so that's why I did it so I'm not
telling you to do it I did it for fun
um fun
um so that's not the point of this talk
so what is the point of this talk
um what I want to talk to you about is
what I learned from watching the
students learn differently from these
two languages like the two cohorts who
chose R versus python
and specifically thinking about how
these different implementations not just
across languages but maybe even across
packages is going to impact
understanding for these users
and specifically I know most people in
this room maybe because the track might
be Educators but I kind of have split
this out into advice for developers or
creators for users of the tools and then
of course most importantly for educators
so let's just dive in so thinking about
like how you learn a new language or how
you translate between languages and now
I'm thinking back to like Spanish and
French
probably the first thing that comes to
mind that's hard that was in my first
example is grammar and specifically like
sentence structure like why do these
same words go in a totally different
order in different languages
and so how I might kind of parallel that
in programming languages is this idea of
what's the structure of your analysis
like you have to do these multiple steps
to do an analysis
um but in different implementations
those steps might happen at different
times
so here's what I mean here's two code
chunks the top one is scikit-learn is
python the bottom one down there is tidy
models is uh you know R of course
and my question to you is when in these
two chunks do we decide which predictors
are going to go into our models it's
just a linear model with a couple of
predictors
and that's happening right here so it
feels kind of the same in both languages
right now right at the moment where you
are fitting the data after you've
specified your model that's when you're
declaring which variables are part of
this model
but then you start thinking about
pre-processing so here's some python
code that includes a step where we are
log transforming both of our
quantitative predictors
and so we've added some stuff to the
process but you can see you know in
Python the pre-processing decision
happens early
and then the decision about which
predictors we're actually doing that to
happens at the fit step
but in tidy models here right we now
have this idea of Russia did this just
go off there we go this idea of recipes
right so the recipe then contains both
the decision about your predictors and
the decision about how you are going to
transform them and even though it's all
together it's actually in the opposite
order you choose your predictors and
then your transformations
and so this is slightly different and
I'm not saying it's wrong like I don't
think that either one is necessarily
wrong but having different approaches is
going to have consequences
and so here's what happened with my
students like the ones that were using
tidy models kind of focused really on
feature selection they really focused on
like which predictors are going to be in
my model and then once they decided that
they were like yeah maybe we could log
transform them
and the ones who use scikit-learn really
focused on like how do we adjust the
data they kind of thought of this
transformation as part of the data
cleaning and they did that first and
then allowed some predictors or others
to be in their model
so what's the takeaway from that
observation well developers I just want
you to be aware of how like your API
design is going to influence how people
think about the actual Concepts right
this is not like a separate thing
um and then
I want when possible if you can be kind
of agnostic if you can allow like I'm
thinking of how you know the recipes and
the model specification and tidy models
it doesn't really matter which order you
declare them they're sort of separate
entities that you've put together later
um I think that's a really good design
Choice personally
and then my last suggestion is just
keeping kind of related decisions
together like I don't necessarily think
second learn is wrong but I don't like
this thing that you go through the whole
setup and then you specify your um
predictors and of course you could like
insert steps where you make another data
frame to kind of solve for that but the
way that it's sort of naturally set up
doesn't keep those decisions together
my advice for users here try to match
your code flow with your narrative where
you have choices you know um if you are
thinking through a problem in a certain
way try to match your code
and then of course like intersperse your
code with text this is why that
discussion and documentation is so
important
um if you're doing two parallel analyzes
in different languages but you have to
kind of Shuffle parts of it
um then you are going to need that
discussion text to help match those up
there we go and then as much as you can
kind of compartmentalize make your steps
modular here's where we choose the model
here's where we choose the predictors
that also kind of lets you swap between
languages
and then my advice for educators here
you know enforce a workflow on your
students that matches the way that you
teach it
um two clicks uh break your analyzes up
same idea as the practitioners if you
are isolating these decisions then when
they see them in different orders they
recognize that decision
and then you know really push students
to document to write what they're doing
to State their decisions outside the
context of the code
all right next thing that I find
difficult in learning languages is false
friends or fosami when I learned French
words that sound really similar and have
different meanings so if I come up to
you later in this conference and I say
this
you're probably going to make that face
if you are not a Spanish speaker but it
turns out I have learned that this just
means I have a cold I'm kind of
congested it doesn't mean what you might
think
or another one you know if you come up
to me and you say your talk was quite
good I'm going to be really happy unless
I find out that you are from the UK or
quite means like meh you know so this
word quite in English uh does not mean
the same thing in every culture
and so what does this look like in code
what it looks like to me you know
similar functions or arguments that
behave differently
so by way of example I want to talk a
little about support Vector machines not
going to teach you support Vector
machines I'm going to do this really
quick we are trying to find a line to
separate these two classes
we want that line to sort of push the
classes apart as much as possible so we
want those dotted lines to be as far
from the solid line but as we push the
classes apart we end up with on the
right hand side those points that are
misclassified or that kind of fall
inside that margin
so when we fit a support Vector machine
we're trying to like minimize that
misclassification maximize that margin
this is the push and pull and so as you
would hope you know in the
implementation in tidy models there is
indeed a parameter that is the cost of
having points fall inside of a margin
and in scikit-learn as you would hope
there is a parameter C that has to do
with the cost of points falling in the
margin
but let's look at those a little more
closely
tidy model's version is the cost of
predicting
wrong so the cost of a sample Landing in
the margin or like on the wrong side
and scikit-learn notice that it says C
the strength of the regularization is
inversely proportional to C
the regularization being that
penalization for misclassification
so these work opposite they're capturing
the same thing they're capturing the
same idea again neither is wrong but
when my students sitting next to each
other using different languages tried
the same values for cost and foresee
because they were trying to tune their
model they got different results and
that was very confusing to them and to
me for quite some time
and so what happens here is that then
the students of course like
conceptualize that penalty differently
so the Tidy model students are
conceptualizing it as a penalty on
misclassification whereas the
scikit-learned students are
conceptualizing it as like a balancing
parameter
um you know a regularization parameter
how much do we balance the margin the
desire for a wide margin with the desire
for Less points inside that margin
so it's it's you know again not wrong
leads to different ideas and so what I
would remind everyone to do is you know
be explicit if you're designing tools I
think cost of misclassification helped
me track down what was going on I think
amount of regularization did not because
regularization is a little more General
um and then you know I don't think I'm
not asking for consistency in
parametrization I'm not asking that you
make sure everything's the same I'm
asking you to be up front because it's
not possible that everything's the same
and people like me need to be able to
track down what the difference is
my advice for educators and
practitioners State everything in words
say things like when the cost is higher
we expect less misclassification and the
cost of that is a smaller margin like if
you say that out loud then you are
understanding that parameter
and then as always you know translate
these choices to non-code language
term three moving swiftly along I think
that learning languages slang terms
become hard my favorite slang term in
English is stand you know this phrase
stand to stand something or to be a
stand
it means you like our big fan basically
we're all stands of R in here
how many of you know where it came from
so this came from a music video and song
by Eminem about like a very obsessed fan
whose name was literally Stan like
Stanley and somehow over the years this
word evolved to mean uh something much
broader and something that is used you
know and people don't even remember that
it came from a person's name
and so I think the equivalent of slang
in code is maybe these like helper
wrapper functions that contain a whole
lot of meaning like way more than what
that one word might suggest
and where I see this in my class is
um in tuning parameters so when you tune
and we're sticking here with those
support Vector machines when you tune
you need to decide which values you're
going to try right
and in both python on top and r on the
bottom you can just sort of manually
create you know kind of that list of
different values that we're going to try
for our model
but tidy models also comes with the
shortcut where we can like access
built-in functions with the names of the
parameters and it will automatically
choose values for you that it thinks are
reasonable
and like I love this I'm not saying this
is bad like I would much rather have Max
[ __ ] decide which values I'm tuning than
me decide that's great right I don't
know why like
.0009 and 32 are better choices than 10
20 30 but I assume Max does or whoever
wrote this part of Tidy models I'm fine
with it
but again this was my biggest shock in
the class
the python students picked it up better
like everyone understood tuning the
first time that I taught it and then
nine weeks of Hands-On activities later
if you asked our students about tuning
they went into detail on the functions
and if you ask the python students they
got the concept we just try a bunch of
different values and see what sticks
and so that was surprising to me and so
I don't really have a device like these
shortcut functions are great I don't
think they should change I'm not saying
that
I do think like again that translating
to English is a good thing
um but most importantly for educators
like it's not clicking for me there we
go the Educators you know think about if
you're using a wrapper function
basically assume that what you're doing
is glossing over that concept so that's
okay like I do this with step PCA I
don't teach all of PCA necessarily when
I'm pre-processing but
um avoid shortcut functions on things
that are actually like learning goals in
your class
okay I got two minutes I think this next
one I will do quickly so the last
challenge I want to point out is like
meaning that isn't in words that's in
gestures
and in the movie in Kanto we have oh
it's not moving this moment where she
points with her lips and I've learned
that this is like a super cool cultural
thing in Colombia that we don't do in
the U.S it's pointing with your lips
so here's your pop quiz in the code
context and I won't make you vote
because I'm low on time
um how what is the question it's not
showing up there we go how does the
k-means function choose initial clusters
we don't know K means ignore it I asked
this on Twitter
this is what people said this is what I
would have said before I dug into this
and it is not correct so here's how I
used to teach k-means
choose your initial centroids by
choosing three random observations
assign all the points to the nearest
centroid recompute the centroids of each
cluster keep going until you have
clusters I've taught it that way for
years it turns out that nothing about
that is correct about how k-means
actually works
I mean it can be you can set it to be
but that is not the default in this
function the default in this function
although it says that it will choose
three initial observations
down there that method hardigan Wong
default method hartigan Wong neither
initializes that way nor does it even
update in the same way as the other
methods so everything I've just told you
is not the default
in scikit-learn they're a little more
upfront but now this initialization K
plus plus
that's different
um
at least they kind of explain it but
they just say it's smart
and then you could think about using
different functions in r
that one contains K plus plus K plus
plus is not an option to this the base K
means function
but now we don't have an option to
choose your iteration process
so there is literally no way to
guarantee at least with these two
implementations that are in the python
output matches
and so what was the results just
frustration just you cannot make that
output be the same with the
implementations people use
and so I think these get repeated I'm
going to skip to kind of my final
takeaways because they contain those
ones
so recap we have these challenges and
these challenges that you see in
language also appear in coding so the
developers in the room what I want you
to do don't assume that the choice of
the parameter name tells people what
that parameter does
don't assume that these default choices
are the obvious choices they're not
Universal you have to document them
and the order that we code is the order
that we think
for practitioners again translation is
not going to be a direct word for word
please discuss what you're deciding
please document please use text
and for educators really what you want
to do is force your students to be
explicit about every decision
so thank you for sticking with me the
slides are whoopsies online oh there we
go please find me please talk to me I'm
going to have to jet to the other talk
foreign